[Música]
hoy quiero comenzar con este slide
diciéndole blanco o negro no siempre
tiene que ser todo y siempre nos tenemos
que ir por el mismo camino
muchas veces encontramos unas escalas de
grises que nos pueden encontrar y
podemos conectar con grandes ideas hay
veces que dejamos esa línea gris a un
lado y esas ideas que tenemos en la
cabeza no las plasmamos no las
compartimos y eso es lo que quiero que
se queden con ustedes cómo podemos
plasmar ideas esta frase me encanta el
pensamiento no creativo es aprendido y
es un estudio que hizo george island
donde le aplicó una prueba a 1600 niños
que tenían 5 años y el del 98% de los
niños que tenían 5 años superó la prueba
de creatividad que le hacen a los
ingenieros que ingresan a la nasa más
preocupante es que cuando los niños
tenían 10 años sólo el 30 por ciento
logró superar esta prueba cinco años
después pero si después a los 30 años
aplicamos la misma prueba sólo el 2% de
la población logra superar la prueba
que los niños de 5 años lograron superar
es por esto que tenemos que aprender a
tener diferentes ideas a encaminarnos ya
lograr hacer cosas diferentes
la imagen que ven acá el niño saltando
en el charco de ovarios que seguramente
son padres de familia cuando seguramente
les ponemos un juguete en la casa sobre
madera sobre papel y les decimos que
están jugando bien pero si el niño
quiere jugar en el charco lo puede hacer
y seguramente ahí va a estar aprendiendo
y su creatividad va a ser diferente les
quiero convertir ahora un comercial de
una de las marcas que se apostó a tener
ideas disruptivas y diferentes de
cualquier mente creativa si seguramente
ustedes puede pensar que este comercial
de una marca como ese toritos lo voy a
poder hacer pero doritos no no lo hice
realmente encontró una idea en cualquier
parte del mundo que lograra conectarlos
con algo diferente disruptivo y no sólo
encontrar una gran idea sino lo
importante que fue este comercial para
ellos pautar este comercial es
supremamente costoso esto se pautó en el
superbowl el segundo más caro para
pautar
historia pautaron comercial acá tiene un
costo de 15 mil millones de pesos y lo
importante de esto es que sólo hay 15
spots de publicidad durante cuatro horas
y 113 millones de personas lo van a
estar viendo en vivo entonces la
pregunta es por qué queremos ideas
diferentes porque queremos apostarle a
la innovación y sobre todo cómo poder
crear con las personas y esto se abre a
través del boom tecnológico que se
llaman las economías compartidas y
cuando comenzamos a hablar de las
economías compartidas encontramos dos
agentes muy importantes primero un
acceso a activos que están siendo
subutilizados y segundo la necesidad de
acceder a más activos pero esto se da
gracias a las economías compartidas y
las plataformas digitales que nos
permiten unirnos y poder plasmar
diferentes cosas a través de la
tecnología
un dato muy importante y es en el 2014
tan sólo el 9% del pib mundial se veía
reflejado en las plataformas o en las
economías colaborativas pero en el 2025
se estima que el 50 por ciento del pib
global se ha reflejado en economías
colaborativas aquí podemos encontrar
diferentes ejemplos pero lo interesante
es como estamos logrando conectarnos y
cómo estamos permitiendo que nuevos
modelos de negocio crezcan a través de
plataformas digitales conectando a las
personas y es aquí cuando comenzamos a
encontrar una palabra que se llama
crowdsourcing esto de francamente
seguramente lo han oído o lo vamos a
confundir con transfondo crowdsourcing
tiene de crowd masa multitud gente y
sourcing de tercerizar pero cómo podemos
utilizar esto para tener ideas creativas
para conectar a las personas y para que
cualquier cualquier mente brillante
pueda expresar sus ideas esto que les
quiero dejar hoy también que es una
frase que me encanta y lo dice el
presidente de chico es como cliente
estoy cansado de sentarme en reuniones
de agencia con un grupo de hombres
blancos heterosexuales
cómo vender nuestras marcas que son
compradas por un 85% de mujeres y
adicional a esto la innovación y
disrupción no aparecen en los grupos
homogéneos de personas qué quiere decir
esto que las ideas están afuera las
ideas están en cualquiera de ustedes
pero lo importante es tener algo y una
herramienta para poder plasmarlas ahora
sí siguiendo con el tema de
crowdsourcing les quiero dar tres
beneficios y porque esto se vuelve tan
relevante para las marcas y para
nosotros el primero tener más ideas
poder que cualquier idea conecte con la
necesidad de un cliente segundo visiones
diferentes seguramente la idea no va a
venir de la mejor y el mejor publicista
y la persona que lleva trabajando diez o
quince años con la marca puede venir de
cualquier persona y segundo tener
visiones diferentes invitar a globalizar
y que esas ideas puedan de venir de
cualquier parte del mundo para hablar de
disrupción en acción quiero poner unos
unos ejemplos que seguramente ya conocen
pero lo interesante es cómo estas
empresas y las economías colaborativas
han seguido creciendo para terminar
quiero hacer un símil
con las economías colaborativa si es erc
de anv y una empresa que tan sólo lleva
10 años ya vale lo mismo que cuesta la
cadena más grande del mundo de hoteles
marriott mariotto 96 años tiene la misma
evaluación que lo que tiene bp andy y
esto lo hace a través de una plataforma
digital ahora cualquier idea puede venir
de grupos trabajo en equipo ideas ideas
ideas eso es lo que quiere hacer que se
planten las ideas en un lienzo pero como
hacemos nosotros para comenzar a
construir una comunidad y aquí viene una
frase que es muy colombiana que va
primero el huevo o la gallina que
necesitamos primero empresas que nos
digan quiero que me conecte con mentes
alrededor del mundo para que me
desarrollen las ideas y quiero comenzar
a construir una comunidad que me logre
resolver necesidades de innovación de
marketing o lo que estemos necesitando y
es aquí cuando se comienza a construir
una comunidad que a hoy ya son más de 90
mil personas alrededor del mundo que
logran resolver retos de innovación y
marketing de las compañías desde la casa
desde donde estén lo único que necesitan
es acceso a internet
para poder plasmar sus ideas ya que hay
algo y es un dato supremamente
interesante y es cómo podemos
democratizar también el mundo de la
publicidad
mujeres y hombres si ustedes ven dentro
de esta comunidad logramos encontrar
casi una equidad de género lo que quiere
decir que también damos oportunidades de
que cualquier persona sin importar el
género pueda participar enviando retos y
esta red se ha convertido en a las redes
globales más grandes la red
hispanohablante más grande y está regada
por más de 115 países ahora fue porque
tienen cosas buenas plataformas como
estas si yo quiero plasmar una idea
primero voy a ganar una remuneración si
una compañía elige trabajar con mi idea
me va a remunerar segundo puedo ampliar
mi portafolio que es más importante para
un diseñador un publicista es poder
ampliar el portafolio pero hay algo que
seguramente no les van a poder dar en
todas las agencias y es poder trabajar
con la marca que ellos se han soñado en
esta plataforma a través de diferentes
retos puedo elegir el reto y trabajar
con grandes marcas
esta persona que ven aquí se llama
infiltrado gentil trago nació en
venezuela y a través de una plataforma
tecnológica en menos de un año y medio
se ha ganado 15 mil dólares lo
importante es que logró salir de una
crisis en su país y hoy reside en en
madrid pero más allá de eso ha logrado
crear para marcas grandes como méxico y
colombia ahora yo como empresario quiero
traer nuevas ideas recordemos el
comercial quiero que mi marca quede la
mente de cada uno de ustedes pero con
cosas que sean totalmente diferentes que
puedo hacer primero reducir costos
segundo intentar encontrar el mejor
talento que el talento puede estar en
cualquier parte del mundo recibir
insights si yo me comienza a dar cuenta
que varias personas me están hablando de
que el brownie tiene que ser no verde
sino azul les comienzo a recibir unos
insights
por otro lado comienzo a generar un
engagement entre mis clientes y mis
consumidores porque estoy abriendo un
reto para que todos creen conmigo
diversidad poder que cualquier persona
comparta conmigo y por último romper
fronteras la idea no tiene que estar
que está al lado mío para cerrar quiero
dejarles con dos ejemplos el primero un
brownie que puede ser la evolución de un
brownie y si nos ponemos a empezar como
empresarios fue un brownie puede tener
chocolate puede tener almendras puede
tener diferentes coberturas pero si yo
invito a la gente a que me diga bueno el
brownie debe tener x ó z y las ideas
vienen de afuera seguramente va a
encontrar unos insights desde los mismos
consumidores que quieren que yo tenga un
nuevo brawn y por último quiero que
entiendan que es este movimiento
cualquiera de ustedes que me diga que es
esto
chocolate y este chocolate se puede
agregar y se puede también relacionar
con muchas otras cosas
una con cliente nos dice oiga
necesitamos hacer una campaña de
chocolate pero seguramente un publicista
muy bueno puede encontrar un concepto
creativo podemos encontrar unas muy
buenas bajadas pero este movimiento y
este gesto también está relacionado
cuando un deportista avanzar las pesas y
se tiene que untar de talco cuando va a
entrar a la cancha y tengo que salir a
correr o simplemente porque tengo frío y
me quiero calentar pero este gesto se
relaciona con lo que es un chocolate de
mesa es por esto que creo fielmente que
una idea puede venir de la mente menos
esperada y sólo necesita la oportunidad
de ser escuchada gracias
y